A single postage
stamp costs $0.44.
How much would a roll
of 1,000 stamps cost?
And there's really a
couple of ways to do it.
And I'll do it both ways just
to show you they both work.
One is kind of a
faster way, but I
want to make sure you
understand why it works.
And then we'll verify
that it actually gives us
the right answer using maybe
the more traditional way
of multiplying decimals.
So we're starting at $0.44.
I'll just write it as 0.44.
Well, that's one stamp.
So this is 1 stamp.
I'll write it like
this, 1 stamp.
How much would 10 stamps cost?
Well, if 1 stamp is
$0.44, then 10 stamps,
we could move the decimal
to the right one place.
And so it would be--
and now this leading 0
is not that useful.
So it would now be $4.4.
Or if you want to make it
clear, it would be $4.40.
Now, what happens if you
want to have 100 stamps?
Well, the same idea
is going to happen.
We're now taking 10
times more, so we're
going to move the decimal
to the right once.
So 100 stamps are
going to cost $44.
And this should
make sense for you.
If 1 stamp is 44/100
of $1, then 100 stamps
are going to be 44/100
of $100, or $44.
Or you could view
it as we've just
moved the decimal
over one place.
So if we want 1,000 stamps,
we'd move the decimal
to the right one more time.
Moving the decimal
to the right is
equivalent to multiplying by 10.
So then it would be $440.
And we could add another
trailing zero just
to make clear that there's
no cents over here.
So if you wanted to
do it really quickly,
you could have
started with $0.44.
And you say look, I'm
not multiplying by 10.
I'm not multiplying by 100.
I'm multiplying by 1,000.
So you're going to have to
put another trailing zero
over here.
And you would move the decimal
from over here to over here.
You've essentially
multiplied this times 10
times 10 times 10,
which is 1,000.
So then this would become $440.
And let's verify that this works
exactly the same if we multiply
it the traditional way, the
way we multiply decimals.
So if you have
1,000 times $0.44.
So you start over here.
4 times 0 is 0.
4 times 1 is 4.
Or, you could just say,
hey, this was 4 times 1,000.
Then we're going to
go one place over.
So we're going to add a 0.
And once again, we're going
to have 4 times 0 is 0.
4 times 0 is 0.
4 times 1 is 4.
Or we just did 4 times 1,000.
So that is 4,000 if you
don't include this 0
that we added here ahead
of time because we're
going one place to the left.
And then we have nothing left.
I haven't at all thought
about the decimals right now.
So far I really just viewed
it as 1,000 times 44.
I've been ignoring the decimal.
So if it was 1,000 times 44,
we would get 0 plus 0 is 0.
0 plus 0 is 0.
4 plus 0 is 4.
4 plus nothing is 4.
And if you ignore the decimal,
that makes a lot of sense
because 1,000 times 4 is 4,000.
And 1,000 times 40
would be 40,000.
So you would get 44,000.
But this, of
course, is not a 44.
This is a 44/100.
We have, between the
two numbers, two numbers
behind the decimal point.
So we need to have
two numbers behind
or to the right of the
decimal point in our answer,
so one, two right over there.
So once again, we get
$440 for the 1,000 stamps.